[Music]
brothers and sisters and dear friends
hope you guys are wearing shadow before
i start i want to praise allah subhanahu
wa tala the most merciful the most trust
or praises glory and gratitude belong to
him
we had a campaign yesterday with a van
and we visited some locations which
you're going to see very soon inshallah
on hijab's channel
the shan's channel as well and many
things happen disturbing things as well
um today we went to the pro-israeli uh
protest to you know stand there on the
palestinian side and uh chant that free
palestine
uh now and just observe what's going on
and just just observe for example what's
going to maybe
well i don't know if we'll get into a
discussion but have a dialogue yeah well
what happened is we was provoked by
i would say three or four cowards yeah
one's a outright
zionist a supporter and a baby killer
supporter
joseph who comes to the apartment in
speaker's corner and he came there with
the cameras and two guys
with israeli flags on a dog and i
actually i was quite happy with that
because that's where the flag belongs i
didn't
have a problem with that but they were
coming there to provoke us and we we're
having our own
protest imagine if i was walking there
with muhammad hijab and two dogs
and he's got cameras sticking on
people's face uh on to the other side
where the
the uh they were uh having their own
protest
i would be provoking them they are
walking and they are surprised
they also by the way there's someone who
threw a bottle absolutely disgusting
yeah uh nobody asked for no one for
anything and the uh bloody he's got his
aim was off which is
vanguard was off yeah the thing is they
came provoked us
and they went back like cows like little
dogs there was two dogs when they came
and five dogs left yeah they left like
dogs between their tails uh
their tails between their legs yeah the
cows and they're trying to dramatize it
in this video that you can see
so just basically to the rally it's a
little bit late we've got the rally and
we've gone around the wrong side of the
palestinian side um
and basically as we're walking through
there's like a gap
back through there to go into the
israeli side
and literally just started just shouting
baby killer
shame on you shame on you and got a
whole crowd rolled up and
him and mohammed hijab just started just
shouting and stuff like that so that
video you saw is this
guy acting like yeah we went there we
took the wrong exit
shut your mouth because what's going to
happen is your little coward the video
is going to come out and in this video
you're going to see how they were trying
to provoke us
and what really happened you're going to
see that the thing is it was clear
that we were a minority there was not
that many of us
but we was outnumbered yeah we were we
are outnumbered it was clear that with
the police presence
that we we were in the middle we had our
flags and the chance
so they came like hijab was saying they
came they could see the flags
and they were coming through and it was
a deliberate
provocation to get a reaction and the
reaction
is what they got yes exactly uh brothers
sisters they came to provoke but they
left with a little stroke
anyways problem says inshallah so what
happened is it we're gonna see
what was happening on the ground yeah
now i don't have a problem with anybody
celebrating
uh their country's flag or their state
as long as it's not stolen
and as long as there is no genocide and
apartheid and ethnic cleansing happening
on the ground
i don't know well of course i don't have
a problem with that i'm not here
to have a problem with these people to
do that just bear in mind guys on my way
there
this footage that you see on my maybe
underneath here playing
is a a occurrence that i had with two of
these cowards
putting their flags out and chanting all
kinds of stuff uh probably
anti-palestine
and when they came across edgewood they
put their flag back in so i pulled up
next to them you can see in the footage
it's going to come out
soon inshallah and i challenged them and
they called me a terrorist
yeah but that's another video that's
going to come out there's just a little
uh taste of what you guys can see on the
screen
now let's get to the main class of the
mata we're going to play you guys a
video and in this video
you are going to see some disturbing
comments and i really want to ask you
guys a question after we watch it so
let's get straight to the video
listen to him carefully now listen to
him carefully and watch what one of the
i don't know if his dad is there or
someone
tells him to come down after he makes a
statement listen carefully
[Music]
[Applause]
first i have no nature
[Music]
[Applause]
you see that he gets towed off to come
back down what does he say
he's shouting and he's saying there is
no palestine yeah i know he's saying
he's saying
it's my effort country and i think he's
saying that basically he's
served in the army or something along
those lines yeah okay now
serving in that army we know what the
army is about you know this is why guys
just imagine
bro imagine if a couple of years ago
when isis existed
imagine a group of muslims coming
together
protesting while it's going on imagine
the hate of the moment where kids have
been blown into pieces
kids have been killed bombed and blown
into pieces civilians have lost their
lives
you guys have provoked the palestinians
by coming attacking masjid al-aqsa
you're stealing lands
it's an israeli proverb now basically if
i don't steal your land somebody else
will
imagine doing that and the muslims come
out with the shahada flags
we come out and we're dancing and we're
celebrating
imagine what the outrage would have
been because that would be direct let me
tell you something prevent would be on
every single one's case in the vicinity
of that protest
and here they are coming out dancing
you know what in in schools kids are
just shout in free palestine yeah
they're getting excluded
they're getting uh referred to to
prevent and you're talking about isis
bro
isis would never get to dance and
even have police protection like it does
those guys would just be arrested
straight away
even though they'd be labeled as
terrorists look watch these these these
cowards let me tell you these guys are
cows yeah
and you can see when they're in groups
they act like big mania you see these
faces if you guys recognize them
i am not calling for any kind of damn
violence against anyone yeah make that
very clear i don't give a damn who it is
i'm not going to they're not my teachers
these people who support the zionist
state
yeah and this uh anti-semitic you can go
to hell
with your anti-semitism nonsense yeah we
don't buy that nonsense anymore yeah
our videos with our jewish friends in
the park with aaron that we had today
and many like joshua and the ones we
have spoken to
is a clear evidence and also the
anti-semitism videos that we've done
about those thugs you were saying rape
jewish women etc is damn clear to that
so when you're saying we don't care
about anti-semitism you mean
that anyone who speaks against
us defending our palestinian brothers
and sisters and labels us for defending
our palestinian brothers and sisters
speaking out and exposing the crimes of
israel yes
that and being labeled as anti-semitism
you can go to hell
i don't buy that i uh me myself i am
against those who are
anti-semitic hundred percent and i'm
vocal about that people know that yeah
look at these faces and when you see
them i just want you to say them shame
on you
you guys make us sick you filthy
individuals
how dare you come there and you're
celebrating and
jumping around imagine you know what i
want to do here guys play this
and we're going to put a little clip no
we know we should do we should play this
and play a little clip brothers and
sisters of them dancing
while what is going on in gaza of people
being killed if
imagine if isis fanbase did this and
we've confronted these isis followers
before
imagine them coming and celebrating
joyfully
in a group when 66 children have been
killed blown into people murdered 132
buildings
have come down yes they have been
decimated yeah yeah
about was it 50 000 people 52
000 that have been displaced yeah these
these are families these
are you know human beings now they've
become statistics
yes you know look even if you don't even
if you don't agree with them
yeah the thing is what's going on here
dancing and you know celebrating and
this is absolutely this is it is inhuman
it's
animals you anyone that's jumping around
like clowns jumping around and saying
what are you there to defend
what are you doing and one more thing
this is
tommy robinson came to this as well why
would tommy robinson
be welcome at a march like this if this
was such a just a march
would you see the likes of tommy
robinson being there why why
wasn't he kind of discarded and said no
you you're going to hurt our cause
don't come over here please because
tommy robinson comes with the security
there's the stuff that's kind of decided
beforehand so
just like any time we do something hamas
no hamas hamas
hamas has become joined with the
palestinian cause
i mean how on earth and why yeah whether
it's ben shapiro whoever it is they join
so now when we do the same oh tommy
robinson
and and this no no tommy robinson we we
we separate ourselves from tomorrow
benjamin netanyahu no no we don't agree
with everything that he said yes
i'm sorry what's with the hypocrisy here
anytime
we say anything oh hamas hamas hamas
copy paste yeah this is just
you made hamas you created hamas you
know hamas if you go
to building you should say made by you
guys and i'm saying you directly funded
it i'm not saying that
you are the cause they exist you coward
you coward
and you can see the reality promises on
the ground these people
they make me sick and when you see these
people you should tell them they should
be ashamed of their self
they are dancing what are you dancing
for innocent people are being blown into
pieces
and you're coming out to prove what
we're trying to say what is that you're
trying to say
you can see that guys and as you can see
this coward here is probably served in
the idf
army probably has a body count god knows
how many palestinians this coward killed
yeah god most how many he killed that's
why he's died or his uncle there had to
tell him you shut your mouth come down
you're making it look he was getting
towed off yeah like a little
pusillanimous boy yeah that's what he
was doing but anyways guys we're going
to keep it nice and short
you saw the reality um we subhanallah
that's the reason why brothers and
sisters
um we did this campaign to show the
reality and the public opinion has done
an absolute u-turn in the context i
wouldn't say
it's always been there for palestinian
but people saw the damn reality now
and that has hurt you a record number of
people
came to the march yesterday 200 000 wow
the biggest palestinian protest in
british history yeah
the damage has been done people have
seen your reality and that is burning
you
we are going to make sure that every
time the word israel is going to be a
synonym for terrorist state
state terrorism that's what it's going
to be a synonym for and our social
experience experience our interviews
with the general public and the jewish
community
are going to come out in a couple of
days inshallah and you're going to see
for yourself guys what's happening look
at these animals
and and today we've heard that aksa has
been stormed yet again yes yes
yeah we've been uh we've heard at least
six hospitals have been
squashed yeah rubble yeah the
coronavirus center
and these people that they're dancing
i'm sorry you have to be a certain
you have to have a really dark hydrogen
rock hard heart yeah that you know
any reasonable individual look what
we're doing it's wrong
yes you may think whatever justification
but
people dying for whatever reason yeah
it's just like when i was speaking to
the guy on speaker's corner
can you condemn the the killing of 66
children yeah but we have to no no no
but we have to but there's about that
but look at these people can you imagine
me saying yep isis killed
yeah but but uh anyways guys these
daughters with their father
and yeah yeah no shame on them no shame
on them yeah
i'm telling you very clearly all you
have to do is when you see them shame on
you that's what i'm gonna say shame on
you
uh that's that's it bro and sisters
until next time i hope you guys uh have
enjoyed well obviously enjoyed this i
hope you guys have been second
to your uh uh stomach to seeing this
disgusting act
and we are going to show the reality of
what the israeli state government
uh that the terrorist government is
doing wrong since the shed is far and
wide
because they might start to shadow
bananas but insisted you need to smash
the algorithm
smash the algorithm until next time
assalamu alaikum
and don't forget to comment inshaallah
it'll keep the algorithms coming inside
and please don't comment
all these seriously guys we're blocking
people now yeah just
talk on the topic oh yeah